cuando crece el número de muertos en
haití pero desciende la atención
mediática e internacional así lo
justificó para france24 william pierdo
ariston doctor en ciencia política y
administración pública no solamente lo
que está pasando en afganistán también
la situación de la pandilla también
muchos países tienen mucho problema para
para resolver a centenares de personas
hacen fila en un campamento de campesino
en los cayos cada familia puede recibir
50 kilos del programa mundial de
alimentos de la onu suficientes para un
mes las ayudas aunque llegan se retrasan
entre las causas por un lado los
deslizamientos de los últimos días tras
fuertes lluvias pero también por la
amenaza de las pandillas que en los
últimos años han desplazado a las
organizaciones es otra cosa también la
inseguridad hace que muchos de estos
personales de los ongs que estaban en el
país ya no están como que la comunidad
internacional es muy exigente de
encontrar una persona de cuánto para
entregar esos fondos aunque a principios
de semana las pandillas habían dado una
tregua para atender a las víctimas del
terremoto del sábado dos médicos fueron
secuestrados en puerto príncipe un
problema que viene de largo la la
garantía el gobierno lo está dando el
problema es que antes del terremoto
había parte esta parte particularmente
el gobierno no tenía control sobre este
esta parte del país haití es el país más
pobre de américa el 7 de julio su
presidente joven el moisés fue asesinado
por mercenarios un estado fallido que
desde el terremoto de 2010 el cual dejó
más de 200.000 fallecidos sigue sin
encontrar el rumbo inmerso en una nueva
tragedia